let's talk now to Alan Fischer who is in
occupied East Jerusalem for us Alan we
mentioned at the top there these uh uh
raids that have been happening in the
early morning in the occupied West Bank
what more we hearing on
that well let me just tell you just in
the last hour we've had confirmation
from the Palestinian authorities that a
fourth person has been killed in what
happened in Janine uh in the late last
night early hours of this morning the
Israeli Army moved in to Janine the had
their bulldozers and armored vehicles
and were accompanied by drones in the
air uh they started to dig up roads
damage infrastructure there the Tactical
advantage of that is unclear but of
course the inconvenience factor is off
the roof and this is not the first time
that this has happened in Janine uh
there were of course clashes because of
what happened the drones were called in
there was a drone strike three people
were killed in that initial dwn strike a
fourth person as we've now confirmed has
been killed as as well and a number of
people were injured one seriously
ambulance and medical workers tried to
get close to those who had been injured
but were blocked obstructed stopped
depending on who you speak to in Janine
uh by the Israelis from getting there
that led to further clashes they those
clashes have been ongoing uh throughout
the morning H and tear gas and smoke
bombs have been fired into the compound
of the local hospital where they're
trying to treat some of those who have
been injured but it's not just in Janine
this is happening across the West Bank
it has been a pattern since the start of
the war there's been an incident in
Bethlehem overnight as well and Janine
of course you'll remember back in July
was the focal point for the largest
Israeli military operation in the West
Bank in more than than 20 years and a
number of people were killed in that 2D
operation uh but certainly the
inconvenience factor for people their
roads are being ripped up their
infrastructure is being damaged and as I
say the Tactical advantage to the
Israelis isn't entirely clear but it's
certainly inconveniencing hundreds if
not thousands of people Alan Fisher life
for us in occupied East Jerusalem